il fallait oser ouvrir une boutique bio
en pleine campagne n'est pas un
challenge facile
construite autour d'un projet d'une
dizaine d'éleveurs et de producteurs la
société coopérative d'intérêt collectif
rassemble aujourd'hui 70 souscripteurs
venus de différents horizons
ce qui en fait son originalité dans une
même structure on va rassembler au
capital des producteurs des
consommateurs des collectivités locales
des associations des acteurs locaux face
à sarre groupe vraiment toutes les
franges relation c'est ce qui nous
intéresse c'est d'impliquer dans l'acte
d'achat il ya quand même un truc
important c'est on se nourrit quoi entre
le magasin le local dispose d'un atelier
de découpe de la viande qui faisait
défaut dans la chaîne de production
depuis son ouverture d'autres paysans
ont rejoint le projet et les animateurs
de la structure recevait ce jour là leur
première classe un moyen concret de
sensibiliser les jeunes à la traçabilité
des produits à une meilleure
connaissance du travail fourni et aux
enjeux en matière de santé et
d'environnement
si en 3e segpa et on fait des sujets en
atelier hsc hygiène alimentation
services nous tout ce qui est sûr
l'alimentation et l'hygiène et du coup
comme c'est un magasin bio et ben on est
venu visiter pour voir ce qu'il y avait
comme alimentation c'était comme produit
j'aime la viande légumes les pâtes les
pommes de terre
tous sauf eux joe biden s'était
intéressé l'as de visiter ce magasin bio
très intéressante et ce alors que tout
est mieux et c'est pas mal pour
l'instant l'ouverture du magasin est
géré par les paysans eux-mêmes qui se
transforme à tour de rôle pour quelques
heures en vendeurs fasse souvent à des
clients avertis car le bio ici fait
partie du paysage
la foire bio déjà été
c'est un événement assez précurseur dans
la région on a été très bien accueilli
ici par la municipalité qui nous a aidé
à créer ce magasin est donc on a cette
chance là d'avoir été vraiment
accueillis dans de très bonnes
conditions
la toute jeune structure n'est pas figé
dans son fonctionnement les coopérateurs
sont prêts à accueillir de nouveaux
venus à condition qu'ils adhèrent à
l'éthique du projet